[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in
nick faldo the cbs lead golf analyst was
on the call
yesterday at kiwa phil let me start out
with uh
or nick let me start out with the poll
question mclovin would you give nick the
poll question
okay most impressive old guy feat phil
mickelson winning at 50
tom brady winning uh super bowl 43
serena winning a major
36 or lebron winning an nba title at 35.
well you know i'm going with phil
because
you know our game demands uh he's an
individual sport okay so he's tennis
um but you know we have to deal with so
much
tennis is a reaction sport isn't that
you
somebody whacks a ball at you and you
leap around and get it but golf you've
got to stand and think about it
and for a long time you're you're doing
you're in the golf course for
five plus hours uh and
it's all that thinking time and to deal
with
you know um the negativity or
you know anything from negativity
frustrations to
loss of trust or whatever that's that's
what i think is so
impressive with this you know when you
get older you look you definitely lose
your nerve phil's had to
fight that in different ways and this
has been a really long process this he
didn't fix this in the last three weeks
or have this dream i'm gonna win this
has probably been a three-year project
you know to get himself physically
strong enough fit enough um you know the
dietary side
all that sort of thing um but then this
mental strength is for me the most
interesting one and when we sat together
at augusta at the
champions uh locker room and you know he
asked me how do you able to concentrate
and i said well i was fine
i said because you know i had you know i
had purpose in every shot even as
even in practice i had purpose um
probably came from when i was a kid
because i you know when i started
playing golf i only had one green one
bunker and one flex i was constantly
aiming at something so every shot had
purpose that happened
accidentally or naturally so you know i
think maybe gleaned a little bit from
this and he went into this new mode of
being able to really focus
and have clear intentions 100 commitment
but more importantly he dealt with a
couple of those bad shots on saturday
really well you know the two paws on uh
you know
there was a 12 and 13 with the t a
couple of little blocks but he hit a
couple of great irons you know
14 and 17 on saturday
comes out dave first green how about
that leaves the first part 15 feet short
and you think wow well that's
makes sense you're 50 the nerves are
gonna get
a bit jangled and no
he had this you could see the way he was
completely in the zone
whether that was probably manufactured
in some ways he had to push himself to
to think think through the process i can
relate to that's what happened to me in
96 it was
you know it was best my best mental
round because i wasn't
as super confident as early 90s
and you have to mentally okay here we go
what am i trying what i want to do
how am i going to do it how's it going
to feel did i do all your check
go through the checklist where before it
happened like that kind of thing
so i think that's why putting all of
that together
this really is a an off the charts
incredible performance what's the first
thing to leave you though as you get
older as a golfer
yeah well i guess it will be some say
touch i would say
it's trust or self belief whatever that
might you know
and again that gets dented i don't know
what the percentage would be but
obviously when you face
shots what you saw last week with
incredible
demand and you can see all the hazards
everywhere you know darn well if i pull
it into that bunk and i go in the hey i
am in trouble um
so that i think is what goes you you
look down at gopro and you're like
i don't like the look of that one i
don't like to look at that shot
and you don't know and you try to deal
with it and you can't
and so if you've gone into a shop
thinking i don't like this it's a bit of
negativity and then it comes off
negative
guess what it's almost like a tick in
the negative box isn't it
where if you can you face that challenge
you look down and go
don't like that light oh this is a
really difficult shot but i can move my
target to yeah that will do me and i can
do this
i can do that so you've walked his way
through and then you stand up and do it
well then you've dealt with the
situation and that's what uh
you know that's what pressure is all
about isn't it it's when you're when
you're
when the the level of the intensity
or the situation you're not prepared for
that's pressure but if you know how to
you have prepared and you know how to
handle the situation that's how you get
you deal with pressure why do you think
phil's the people's champion
well he gives he gives back he gives
good entertainment um
you know he's he's not he he's a full-on
entertainer now look at the you know
he's social media or you know he loves
to entertain
and he he comes up with his own words
now what have you
first man to call a sec a chip shot sexy
you know
things like that so uh but you didn't
play that way you
you were pretty focused like could you
have engaged
played to the crowd at all i would have
i've
i would have loved to because i i
believed um
against your beliefs isn't it and where
you where you come from and how you talk
you know i
believe to stay focused and play within
myself
and you know i had to do that and then i
and i kind of kicked myself
because as you can tell i've got a bit
more personality than what i probably
displayed on the golf course that my
very good friend sports psychiatrist
i could have taught you to switch in and
out you could have switched off and gone
and reacted with the crowds
stolen the kids bag of chips or
something you know something silly
come back to the bag and then go as soon
as you grab put your hand on the drive
ahead or something you can go back into
golf mode so
i kind of wish i'd known that a lot
earlier but i didn't
but you know phil stayed in golfing mode
that whole weekend and probably the
whole week but obviously very evident at
the weekend how
you know some psychologists were saying
you got to wander off and
dream of the purple monkey and all this
sort of thing but no
he he walked and he was completely
engrossed in what he was doing and
staying and controlling himself and i'm
sure
his heart was leaping out of his chest
at times but you know he didn't
and you know he played great yes he hit
some really great shots some unsung
great shots like the hit a five iron out
but rough at the ninth
i mean that was a seriously good goal
shot that you know that won't get
talked about but for me when i saw that
you know landed it 20 feet
i was like wow you know that was very
impressive the two shots down
10 very impressive and uh
and to have all and to have all of that
that incredible uh atmosphere between
all those
exchanges you know we've never known
anything like anything yet they had five
exchanges of two shots some more three
shots on the second half
that's we get one of those a weekend in
the tournament
we will go or maybe there's a two shot
swing here and it doesn't happen
but have five of them in ten holes that
was i thought that was riveting stuff
wasn't it i thought you couldn't uh
go for all non-golf but that was that
was worth watching more impressive
though tiger in 2019 in augusta or phil
this weekend yeah well tiger is another
amazing you know tiger went in 11 years
and all the surgeries and all that sort
of thing
um and and yes of course tigers
number one number one your choice jackal
tiger who's
who's the greatest so you know that i
think
the tiger come back was greater than
this
phil one but you know this is um an
incredible
it's like that's why you have these
shows you can sit and argue for hours
whether it's one two or three but
phil doesn't act look or play like he's
50 nick
no well that's he that's credit to him
yeah his commitment but
unbelievable but unbelievable commitment
you've got to give him credit for that
he's change
i spoke to him at the masters in in
november because i went straight to
so you know how do i get more clubhead
speed because he's done a great job very
few
you know it as you get older the club
goes slower doesn't it but he suddenly
comes out with six miles an hour
more clubhouse where six threes are 18.
that's how we work it six you know
marlin now gives you three yards so 18
more yards 20 more yards
and i said like a rookie how do i get
more clarity well he went to the starts
of the mind
you've got to train the mind to to get
tailor body to move faster
and you know okay so take and then you
go to the gym and you start working
specific exercises you know to get
the power in the body in the right place
the explosion so you go through all
these different pros before you start
swinging
speed sticks and things like that to get
the club you know otherwise you'd tear
your shoulders or something
so it wasn't a that was not a five
minute process you know that was
months of training to build up to get to
that
and you know the dietary done crazy diet
things you know when he goes on
whatever he goes on you know his fruit
diet for a week or so right before the
open
couple years but anyway it's commitment
incredible commitments you can't you
cannot knock that in any way i thought
what brooks kepca was attempting to do
was equally impressive yeah
i mean nick he had a dislocated knee he
had ligament damage
he had surgery in march yeah
i mean he's on one leg at augusta yeah
but
for him to be out there in the final
group i mean
that again pretty impressive he i did
mention if phil was
yes the weekend goes it's a mental game
phil's looking mentally looking after
his actual mind
and his technique and and brooks was
mind was looking after his body
i gleaned that his team unbelievably
concerned as he
even said we've got five people watching
you train and watching this knee
but he said he was taped up he was on
painkillers all sorts of things like
that but they just wanted to get him
to mundy um you know that he knew
actually the hardest thing apparently
was you know walking from
green to t through all the different
sand areas and the wood planks and also
he was really concerned that one little
slip
and he was even concerned apparently
even playing off uneven lies you know
even one knee up one knee down so you
know that was a
that was a huge mental effort on him and
uh
just making it just coming out and
driving it poorly for that front nine i
mean if he'd hit a decent tee shot on
number two
after bird birdie and one might have
been a very different story but it
wasn't it
you know he faltered he really struggled
to get the ball on the fairway
until he finally found a couple at the
end so uh
that uh the phil got the up you know
money to get the upper hand
but also you look at the par fives that
was the difference phil was
three under and and uh brooks was three
over
three yeah brutal yeah brutally yo so he
pulls the t-shirt on two
clatters in the trees probably fortunate
he didn't go in the hazard or
and then i don't know why i i called it
on there i said i don't know why he
tried to hit a three-wood on a
left-to-right winds
on seven and blocks into those trees you
know if that would have been for me
sensible knock it down front edge rather
80 yards 60 80 yards pitch it in that
would have been a different story
so um and again and then he was
struggling off the team
through down 11 10 and 11 cost him a
couple there
so yeah he hey phil
played beautifully you know he thought
about every shot committed everything
short game was amazing
um didn't really miss a putt that really
was going to be like wow he's in trouble
so it was excellent stuff what would you
have shot on that course
yesterday i'd still be finishing it
he's still out send out the search party
no it's like when they
they run the marathon and then there's
the guy who's taking eight hours to run
the mirror yeah he
comes in the next morning no i uh i
would
i would hate i would hate to think on
that wind
um no i would be
i'd be lucky to break 80. i really would
i really would i think i
actually might take i would take a 78
right now sitting here right now
really what's the biggest number you
ever had on a whole
i think i think i had a 10
once i think but you kind of delete that
from your mouse i'm going with
one if i'm being really honest i think
it's once but i probably tell everybody
no
9 was my worst what's that like though
when you're writing down a 10
it's it's it's
numbing isn't it because you well i can
tell you how i feel when i
write yeah yeah yeah yeah but when you
got you got three on the card
but yeah when you do it for the first
time and then see i used to
play with simon hobdy and you don't need
to cook a ten on one hole and he goes
okay simon
simon he said relax you know ten times
count count to ten good idea to simon
count his hand it's one two three four
five six seven eight nine
let's out your mightiest f screaming
across the goal of course
ten just okay so i feel a lot better now
that's better okay
so hey there's some great players who
put up big numbers
well last week i came up with a stat
which i was amazed um
2010 they had a hundred and ten players
had
seven or more wow well sorry it was 110
times it happened
yeah how about and i think we may have
we were very close to it again so that
is
quite shocking is it it's that there
were seven eight nines and tens last
week
yeah humbling sport it sure
is sure is wait it's great to talk to
you
and all right thanks do you do you have
any of your trophies there
i do what do you want to say well let me
see what uh
so you guys are fancy you got you got
three masters
yeah give me a second okay all right
so uh nick faldo there with his uh he
won
three open championships and won the
masters three times
finished second at the pga championship
and second at the u.s
open so they these are really special
because look they're they're like half
size
so originally
so originally we weren't allowed to make
a
full-size one as our replica let's do it
ourselves
so i had these made by the garage the
garage of london or the crown jewelers
and you you can't
but these are so unique because even on
the flute there i've got all the names
here it took him three months to engrave
them
so these are works of art because all
the names as best we can
and and the plinths so those are pretty
darn special
can you what else do you want to see do
you drink out of the claire john
of course you can what a silly question
yeah look it's it works he's got his
hand have you have you
had a drink out of the clarity yeah of
course okay of course you've got
to have a splash of clarity
and then you have your uh they give you
a miniature masters
no hang on okay all right
he's running like a little kid
it's like he's in somebody else's house
here yeah
oh okay there you go oh i love
that day the days are really special
where's the uh where's the front door
yeah that's the that's the right way
around ah
so we we didn't get these until
um 1990 was the first one so i had to
have another one for 89 made
which um which year is this one
that's always nice when you can break
which one is that
yeah oh there you go that is 1989 you
know the
your first one that's great
hey it's great to always catch up with
you thanks for
thanks for guided tour of the treasure
yes yes
well it's nice to have a trophy case
let's put it that way
that's yours that's yours in front of
you isn't it uh i got some
i got some sports emmys here but
how about could i give you three sports
emmys for one claret
jug uh no okay all right
okay all right fair enough fair enough
these are like well i'm sure your images
are
like babies too as well but these are
these are babies
yeah yeah well you won those
i needed help to win mine yeah there you
go well fanny helped you too
yeah she did a good job pulled the right
club here and there yeah yeah yeah and
you listened to her uh
hey thanks as always great stuff this
past weekend thank you buddy
all right cheers good to see you thank
you more phone calls are best and worse
coming up right after this